okay before we talk about
ai and the amazing work you're doing let
me ask you ridiculously we're both
russian
so let me ask you a ridiculously
romanticized russian question
do you think human beings are
alone like fundamentally on a
philosophical level
like in our existence when we
like go through life do you think
just the nature of our life is
loneliness yeah so we have to read
dostoevsky at school
as you probably know yeah
i mean it's part of the your school
program um
so i guess if you read that then you
sort of have to believe that
um you're made to believe that you're
fundamentally alone
and that's how you live your life how do
you think about it you have a lot of
friends
but at the end of the day do you have
like a longing
for connection with other people that's
maybe another way of asking it do you
think that's ever fully satisfied
i think we are fundamentally alone we're
born alone we die alone but
um you know but i view my whole life as
trying to
get away from that trying to not feel
uh feel lonely and again we're talking
about you know subjective
kind of way of feeling alone it doesn't
necessarily mean that you don't have any
connections or
you are actually isolated you think it's
a subjective
uh thing but like again another absurd
measurement wise thing how much
loneliness do you think there is in the
world
so like if you see loneliness as a
as a condition how much of it
is there do you think like how
i guess how many you know there's all
kinds of studies and measures of
how much you know how many people in the
world feel alone there's all these
like measures of how many people are
you know self-report or just all these
kinds of different measures
but in your own perspective
how big of a problem do you think it is
size-wise
well i'm actually fascinated by the
topic of loneliness i try to read about
it
as much as i can um what really
and there i think there's a paradox
because loneliness is not a clinical
disorder it's not
something that you can get your
insurance to pay for if you're
struggling with that
yet it's it's actually proven and pretty
you know tons of papers tons of research
around that it has proven um
that it's um correlated with earlier uh
life
expectancy shorter life span and it is
you know in a way like right now what
scientists would say that it you know
it's a little bit worse than
being ob so not actually doing any
physical activity
in your life the impact on your
interests have an impact on your
physiological health yeah so
it's basically puts you if you're
constantly feeling lonely
um your body responds like it's
basically all the time under stress
so it's always in this alert um alert
state
and so it's really bad for you because
it actually like drops your immune
system and get
it your response to inflammation is
quite different so
all the cardiovascular vascular diseases
actually responds to
viruses so it's much easier to catch a
virus that's sad now that
we're living in a pandemic and it's
probably making us a lot more alone
and it's probably weakening the immune
system making us more susceptible to the
virus
it's kind of sad
yeah the statistics are the sticks are
pretty pretty horrible around that so
around 30
of all millennials report that they're
feeling lonely constantly
30 30 and then it's much worse for jan z
and then twenty percent of millennials
say that they feel lonely and they also
don't have any
close friends and then um i think
twenty-five or so and then twenty
percent would say they don't even have
acquaintances
that's the united states that's in the
united states and i'm pretty sure that
that's much worse everywhere else like
in the uk i mean it was white
widely like tweeted and uh posted when
they were talking about a minister of
loneliness that they wanted to appoint
because four out of ten
you people in uk feel lonely so i think
we don't understand
loneliness i mean that i think that
thing actually exists
um so yeah you you you will die
sooner if you if you are lonely and
again that
this is only when we're only talking
about your perception of loneliness or
feeling lonely
that is not objectively fully so being
fully socially isolated
however the combination of being fully
socially isolated
not having many connections and also
feeling lonely that's pretty much a
deadly
combination so it strikes me bizarre
or strange that this is a wide known
fact and then there's really no one
working really on that because it's a
subclinical it's not clinical it's not
something that you can
we'll tell your doctor and get a
treatment or something yet it's
killing us yeah so there's a bunch of
people
trying to evaluate like try to measure
the problem by looking at like how
social media is affecting loneliness and
all that kind of stuff so it's like
measurement
like if you look at the field of
psychology they're trying to measure the
problem
and not that many people actually but
some
but you're basically saying how many
people are trying to solve
the problem like how would you
try to solve the problem of
loneliness like if you just stick to
humans
i mean or basically not just the humans
but the technology that connects us
humans
do you think there's a hope for that
technology
to do the connection like are you on
social media
much unfortunately do you find yourself
like uh again if you sort of introspect
about
how connected you feel to other human
beings how not alone you feel do you
think social media makes it better or
worse
maybe for you personally or in in
general
i think it's it's easier to look at some
stats and
um i mean gen z's seem to be generation
z seems to be
much lonelier than millennials in terms
of however they report loneliness
they're definitely the most connected
you know generation in the world i mean
i still remember life without without an
iphone
uh without facebook they don't know that
that ever existed
uh or at least don't know how it was um
so that tells me a little bit about the
fact that that might be
um you know this hyperconnected world is
might actually make people feel lonely
lonelier
i don't know exactly what the what the
measurements are around that but i would
say in my personal experience i think it
does make you feel a lot lonelier
mostly yeah we're all super connected uh
but i think loneliness the feeling of
loneliness doesn't come from
not having any social connections
whatsoever again tons of people that are
in long-term relationships experience
bouts of loneliness and continued
loneliness
um and it's more the question about the
true connection about actually
being deeply seen deeply understood
um and in a way it's also about your
relationship with yourself
like in order to not feel lonely you
actually
need to have a better relationship and
feel more connected to yourself then
this feeling actually starts to go away
a little bit and then you
open up yourself to actually meeting
other people
in a very special way not just you know
add a friend on facebook kind of way
you